[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 lactu en
26 minutes nous allons faire le tour de
l'actualité locale mais d'abord les
titres de ce mercredi 29 janvier les
chiffres de la délinquence sont
maintenant connus dans le département a
noté une augmentation des cambriolages
et des infractions économiques et
financières
le maire de coignère sera candidat à sa
succession Henry paay est élu maire donc
depuis 89 il va briguer un nouveau
mandat c'est l'invité de cette édition
un trésor du 17e siècle découvert dans
l'église de Mani les hameau les travaux
de rénovation ont mis à jour un tableau
que l'on croyait être une copie et qui
s'avère être un original les
explications dans quelques instants avec
Philippe Luz mais nous ouvrons tout
d'abord cette édition avec l'image du
jour celle de Caroline fruchot que nous
avons ont suivi hier lors de l'étape
régionale qualificative pour le
championnat de France du dessert
championnat qui aura lieu à Nice en mars
prochain et bien il y avait cette
candidat et parmi eux cette étudiant du
lycée hôtelier de 5 an en ieline en
spécialité pâtisserie et bien Caroline
doit se contenter malheureusement d'une
deuxe place et bien ces desserts à base
de poir n'auront pas tout totalement
séduit le jury qui ont préféré les
agrumes mais bonne chance donc à cette
étudiante qui se destine à une car hier
hier en France mais aussi à l'étranger
et son portrait complet sera à retrouver
demain jeudi dans l'émission filco
présenté par Clerc Cambier félicitations
tout de même à cette étudiante du lycée
hôtelier de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline voilà on continue on passe une
information santé nous en avons parlé
dans l'émission checkup octobre rose
c'était l'opération consacrée à la lutte
contre le cancert du sein elle a eu lieu
en octobre dernier nous avions suivi en
particulier le travail mené par les
centres socio-culturels et les ateliers
socio-linguistiques de trappe et bien
une exposition retraçant les différentes
animation mené pendant ce mois d'Octobre
Rose est actuellement à découvrir dans
les centres de la commune pour les
participantes l'expérience semble avoir
été très positive je vous rappelle que
cette maladie le cancer du sein touche
une femme sur H et nous écoutons à ce
sujet Isabelle Bertrand je vois qu'elles
ont intégré complètement les messages
donc du dépistage tous les 2 ans à
partir de 50 ans aller voir
régulièrement sa gynéco sont des choses
que qu'elle porte et que les hommes
portent parce qu'il y avait des hommes
aussi dans les groupes et et qui ont
vraiment témoigné en disant qu'ils ne
voulaient pas parler de de cela parce
que c'était pour eux un sujet intime et
maintenant ils en parlent librement et
se sentent ben pris dans dans le
dépistage organisé et puis comme ayant
une place en tant que homme auprès de
leurs mère leurs filles et leurs
compagnes un tout autre sujet maintenant
pas de mieux sous le ciel de la
délinquence dans les ivelines un rapport
sur l'action de sécurité en 2013 vient
d'être présenté en préfecture
73464 c'est le nombre de faits constatés
et parmi ces faits à noté une
augmentation du nombre de cambrolage de
plus 14 % les escroqueries et les
infractions financières et économiques
ont également progresser elle de plus de
%. mitigé c'est ainsi que le préfet a
qualifié le bilan sécurité 2013 dans le
département des ivelines le point noir
ce sont les cambriolages en progression
de 14 %. cette augmentation était
principalement concentrée sur le prer
semestre et un peu moins sur le second
semestre ce qui pourrait laisser croire
que les efforts que nous avons fait en
la matière commencent à porter leur
fruit mais nous verrons évidemment
encore en 2014 si c'est le cas il y a
euh trois types de cambrioleurs 1/3 des
cambrioleurs sont le fait de résidents
du département 1/ers de cambrioleur
résideent dans la région Île-de-France
et un tiers de cambrioleur viennent de
plus loin et plus
particulièrement pour un nombre d'entre
eux d'un certain nombre de pays d'Europe
centrale en parallèle de ces chiffres
des taux d'élucidation qui augmentent
avec de nouveaux moyens de coordination
des groupes d'enquêtes professionneles
ont par exemple été constitués j'ai
voulu spécialiser moi des équipes la
police nationale a fait exactement la
même chose des équipes de lutte contre
les cambriolages des enquêteurs qui qui
travaillent exclusivement sur ces
phénomènes avec de bons résultats et
finalement lorsque vous voyez tout ce
qui est indicateur d'activité des
services en gendarmerie nous avons une
hausse des taux d'élucidation nous avons
15 % de fait élucidés en plus les
atteintes au bien nous avons une hausse
de l'ordre de 2 % de notre taux
d'élucidation associé à cela une réponse
judiciaire plus forte les comparutions
immédiates sont en augmentation en 2013
de 15 %. nous en faisons environ 6 par
jour ouvrable au parc au tribunal de
Versailles ce qui est un chiffre assez
élevé ce qui correspond à la volonté de
réprimer rapidement et fermement les
comportements les plus graves mais aussi
les plus simples tous les cambrioleurs
majeurs sont déférés devant le tribunal
en comparation immédiate tous les
camburs mineurs sont déferés devant juge
pour enfant 40 % des interpellations se
font sur appel à 17 donc nous continuons
à attirer l'attention de des voisins
pour dire si vous constatez quelque
chose de de pas normal dans votre
voisinage n'hésitez pas appel le 17 à
côté des cambriolages qui progressent
l'autre préoccupation ce sont les
violences physiques les conflits de
voies publique et les conflits
intrafamiliaux les escroqueries et les
infractions financières et économiques
liées au développement d'Internet sont
en progression de près de 14 %. enfin
dernière infraction en Haus lié cette
fois au stupéfiants entre 2010 et 2013
les trafics et reventes ont augmenté de
109 %. autre point noir soulevé lors de
la présence entation de ce rapport les
chiffres de la sécurité routière le
nombre d'accidents est en baisse de 7 %
le nombre de blessés en diminution celui
des tué sur la route est stable
toutefois les responsables pointent du
doigt les 15 piétons tués cette année
ils n'était que qure en
2012 voilà et puis pour relier cette
thématique avez-vous le sentiment d'être
en insécurité c'est la question que nous
sommes alleer vous poser notamment dans
les rues de montig le Bretonneux vos
réponses au micro d'Étienne Dang
oui sur Montini je suis je me sens en
sécurité oui j'ai jamais eu de problème
je rencontre pas de gens bizarres dans
le dans la rue donc j'ai vraiment pas de
problème avec ça oui mais enfin il y a
quand même à refaire quand même he ouais
il y a des fois il y a des bandes des
fois c'est vrai que quand ils sont
plusieurs c'est vrai qu'ils font leur
Manin quoi moi je ne vois rien d'anormal
oui
hein à part il on a peut-être des
cambriolages mais ça c'est question de
de police euh oui je me sens en sécurité
ouais euh je suis tranquille quand je me
promène dans la ville plusieurs fois je
vois passer les voitures de police ça me
rassure mais moi personnellement je
trouve ça calme à mon dîner pouronne ok
voilà pour la réaction des habitants à
Montine bretonne on va partir maintenant
du côté de coignère Henri paayux bonsoir
vous êtes maire de coignère depuis 1989
et vous non 86 86 pardon oui et vous
sollicitez un nouveau mandat vous serez
opposé pour l'instant vous n'avez qu'un
seul concurrent c'est Didier Fiser alors
d'abord j'aurais une première réaction
sur les on a entendu les chiffres de la
délinquence est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ce thème de
l'insécurité pourrait être au centre de
la campagne des des municipales à venir
non je n'ai pas le sentiment que cela
puisse être un thème de campagne parce
que à coanière finalement comme dans
toutes les communes je dirais à d're
dimension il y a des problèmes comme
partout mais je dirais que de ce côté-là
je suis quand même assez rassuré
aujourd'hui il y a eu plus de problèmes
il y a une vingtaine d'années qu' en a
aujourd'hui
je rappelle je vais rappeler vos le
résultat c'est vrai que vous avez été
élu en 2006 cétait la suite du départ du
maire et réélu enertvant oui Robert Vian
tout à fait est réélu en 2008 dès le
premier tour avec plus de 61 % des voix
face à la candidate divver gauche
marieclaude redau alors ma première
question donc vous êtes maire de la
commune de coignè depuis 1986 qu'est-ce
qui motive à repartir pour un nouveau
mandat ben écoutez ce sera un 6e mandat
j'avoue que j'ai sérieusement réfléchi
pour savoir si je devis y retourner à
nouveau et je pense que j'ai encore de
grands services à offrir à la ville de
coadière et au coierrière vous avez pas
peur un peu de l'usure du pouvoir non
pas spécialement je dirais que j'ai
toutes les facultés intellectuelles pour
poursuivre et comme je vous l'ai dit
j'ai des services à rendre et je
continuerai à les rendre je suis en
politique depuis 1958 avec le retour du
général de Gaul je suis ce qu'on
pourrait appeler agoniste social donc un
séginiste un fillioniste aujourd'hui
pour N retransplanté je dirais à
l'époque à laquelle on est euh et euh
donc j'ai pris cette décision donc de
repartir une nouvelle fois pour un 6e
mandat vous avez dit que vous aviez
quand même réfléchi euh à l'envie ou pas
de de repartir c'est vrai qu'autour de
vous dans les communes alentours on voit
un certain rajunissement de la classe
politique notamment avec Pierre
sellincour à la verrière qui a passé sa
la main au cours de mandat encore Jeorge
Mougeot àourpa qui a annoncé que lui ne
se représentait pas est-ce que vous
n'avez pas eu envie à un moment donné où
la question ne s'est pas posé euh de
passer la main au cours de monde on
avait évoqué la candidature de votre
premiier ad jooindre josenne Gorgibus
oui la question s'est posée c'est vrai
Josan goribus ma première adjoint donc
qui est en retraite aujourd'hui depuis
maintenant 4 ou 5 ans et bien alors que
je pensaer qu'elle pouvait effectivement
prendre le relais et bien m'a expliqué
que elle souhaitait se retirer pour
profiter de sa retraite et que
voulez-vous que je dise à ça c'est un
regret quand même elle était très
impliquée sur la regret parce que
j'estimibus avait les qualités et avait
la compétence et l'expérience donc elle
ne sera pas présente sur votre liste
elle sera pas présente sur ma
liste avant de vous demander comment
vous allez mener campagne et puis vous
avez dit qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire sur coignè je voudis
qu'on écoute Valérie PC c'est la
présidente départementale de l'UMP et la
question qu'on lui a posé c'est pourquoi
l'UMP ne vous a pas donné son
investiture pour les élections
municipales et puis je vous ferai réagir
après vous allez voir c'est assez court
on écoute Valée
PC bah à coignère Henry paayux n'a pas
souhaité d'investiture et donc nous
n'avons pas reçu de demande
d'investiture sur coignère voilà c'est
net on n' pas reçu de demande
d'investiture pourquoi vous avez pas
sollicité l'investiture bien et bien
tout simplement parce que la liste qu
démocratie que je mène qui a été créé
par robertv en 77 et bien les principes
de cette liste c'est que nous ne
faisions pas de politique àanière depuis
86 je n'ai jamais d'enquanière dist
attribuer le moindre tracte pour appeler
à voter pour un tel ou un tel bien que
et tout le monde le sait à quoi dire je
suis RPR je suis aujourd'hui UMP mais
j'estime que dans une ville on va dire à
taille humaine 4500 habitants et bien la
politique je dirais ne peut que gâcher
la convivialité que je souhaite mettre
en place et c'est la raison pour
laquelle donc je ne sollicite pas
d'investiture et ni ni d'autres
investitur ni rien du tout dès l'instant
où c'est politique et d'ailleurs je
dirais mes colissers sont parfaitement
avertis je les sélectionne sur des
critères qui sont des critères locaux et
non pas sur des critères politiques il
est peut-être possible que dans ma liste
sortante j'ai peut-être des gens qui
sont de sensibilité de gauche je n'en
sais
rien vous allez la définir votre liste
alors ma liste c'est une c'est une liste
on va dire on peut la cataloguer si on
veut de divers droitees dans la mesure
où j'ai sur ma gauche je dirais un
candidat du Parti
socialiste et voilà d'accord mais en
dernières élections alors cantonnal de
mars 2008 puisque vous étiez conseiller
général même vice-président du conseil
général vous l'aviez pourtant cette
investiture alors qu'est-ce qui a changé
oui il y a il y a une différence entre
une élection cantonale et une élection
municipale
euh non c'est pas une élection je dirais
qu'une élection municipale c'est une
liste alors que une élection cantonale
c'est un candidat c'est tout à fait
différent d'une part et d'autre part il
faut quand même savoir une chose c'est
que on rentre là je dirais dans une
élection cantonale dans le casre d'une
élection on va dire politique et un
candidat qui n'a pas d'investiture n'a
strictement aucune chance je dirais de
passer ou extrêmement peu d'accord euh
on va revenir sur sur coignère quel quel
regard vous portez sur le travail
accompli sur sur coignère vous dites il
y a encore des choses à faire parce
qu'on a on a vraiment l'impression d'
d'un équilibre entre le côté village
effectivement parce qu'il y a quand même
assez peu d'habitants à coignè quand on
traverse votre ville c'est pas ce qui
peut sembler parce qu'il y a il y a tout
un fort développement économique
qu'est-ce qu'il y aurait encore à faire
oui c'est une ville effectivement
extrêmement atypique 4500 habitants
c'est une ville de taille on va dire
relativement modeste mais par contre
depuis 86 je travaille je dirais sur le
développement économique de la ville
pour une raison simple c'est que j'ai
réussi ce développement il faut savoir
quand même que en
1986 parmi les villes les plus riches du
département des ivelines par habitant
coignère était au fond de la classe
aujourd'hui j'ai réussi à la IC après 30
ans d'efforts à la deux placeire à la
2uxè place parmi les plus riches du
département le résultat de tout ça c'est
quoi ce sont les impôts deux fois plus
faibles que dans tout le secteur ce sont
des services à la population je dirais
extrêmement importants à des tarifs je
dirais qui défi toute concurrence par
rapport à ce qui se passe à côté et
voilà le résultat donc d'ailleurs votre
votre opposant Didier Fiser donc qui est
candidat socialiste dit Queen matière de
fiscalité vous avez encore fait le choix
de baisser les impôts ils sont encore
baissés et il dit que lui c'est
électoraliste bon j'ai fait des efforts
extrêmement impressionnants pendant qure
mandats ou 5 mandats je sais plus où
j'en suis et là-dessus il se trouve que
le mandat 2008 2014 est un mandat tout à
fait exceptionnel parce que je n'ai
jamais autant développer et fait
d'investissement dans la ville quand que
ces six dernières années tout ça est dû
justement B à la richesse que j'ai
réussi à créer sur quadière est-ce que
c'est pas et surprise et surprise je
dirais lors du vote du budget préitif
2013 j'ai eu la surprise après avoir
financé tous les investissements que
j'ai fait et ceux qui sont encore au
cours de réalisation qui sont financés
j'ai eu la surprise qu'il me restait de
l'argent j'avais la possibilité
éventuellement de baisser la dette oui
mais la commune de coer a une dette
extrêmement faible d'une part et les
empruns que j'ai fait le dernier emprun
que j'ai fait 4 million d'euros est un
emprunt pour financer des équipements
qui vont servir à des générations et
donc j'ai estimé d'ailleurs c'est le
rôle un petit peu de l'emprunt dans le
cadre de une gestion communale et bien
c'est que il n'est pas normal de faire
supporter à une seule génération
l'ensemble des investissements que l'on
fait qui vont servir aux générations
suivantes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle et bien comme j'avais de
l'argent qui me rester que je n'avais
plus de besoin particulier en
invvestissement et bien j'ai décidé donc
de baisser les
impôts en disant ça vous faites
certainement rêver d'autres d'autres mer
oui absolument j'ai décidé donc de les
baisser de 10 % d'une part mais
également de baisser tous les services
offerts à la population les
garderies les centres aérés les classes
de neige les
les autres séjours de neige qu'on offre
également la au comment s'appelle à des
jeunes je dirais dans le cadre d'une
activité qu'on a créé sur la ville j'ai
j'ai baissé tout cela de 10 % également
c'est le le point principal de de votre
programme merci en tout cas Henri paayux
d'être venu sur le plateau du du 78
lactu puis je rappelle que vous êtes
candidat à votre succession sur la ville
de coignère dont vous êtes le maire
depuis
1986 absolument et je vous remercie
d'avoir reçu merci beaucoup allez
direction maintenant Montini le breton
au sein de l'espace Saint-Quentin alors
vous vous en souvenez certainement de
l'ancien cinéma Gomon et bien ces salles
vont bientôt renaître puisqu'elles vont
accueillir un bowlying celui qui était
auparavant implanté dans le centre
commercial des Sky West Anthony r fait
le point pour nous les 15 pistes sont
déjà installées débuté en octobre
dernier les travaux du nouveau bowling
donnent forme ici à l'espace central et
à la future salle de réunion ouverte aux
entreprises et aux associations après
c'est toute la décoration finale là pour
l'instant on a terminé tout ce qui était
ventilation
installation des comment on appelle ça
de la
climatisation après il y a tous les
tests à mettre en route on a déjà fait
les sanitaires auparavant implanté au
centre commercial Skywest le bowling
s'apprête à s'installer dans l'ancien
complexe de six salles de cinéma
imontain sur près de 2000 m Carr il y a
deux trois salariés de bowling star qui
était déjà salariés de l'ancien
établissement qui vont reprendre euh
pour le reste ce sera de embuche locale
l'entrée principale donnera sur le quai
François truffau pour ceux qui se
souviennent cette entrée correspondra à
l'une des anciennes sorties proches de
la médiathèque du canal il y aura
également des billards pour les amateurs
le bowling devrait ouvrir ses portes fin
février allez on quitte Montini le
breton pour une découverte inattendue en
l'église Saint-Germain de Paris de manie
lesameau prix depuis un siècle pour une
simple copie et bien un tableau
représentant Saint-Jérôme s'est avéré
être un original une œuvre du maître
italien Guido Renny Olivier Maniscalco
et lodim
moine une découverte historique pour
Manil etamo c'est en 2012 alors que les
archives du Conseil Général des Yvelines
font l'inventaire des biens de l'église
Saint-Germain de Paris qu'un tableau
censé n'être qu'une simple copie est
mise en restauration pourtant à
l'automne dernier le diagnostic tombe et
il est inattendu le tableau représentant
Saint-Jérôme est un original du 17e
siècle une œuvre inestimable du du
maître italien GUID Renny un trésor qui
demeurait dans l'anonymat la première
fois que j'ai eu l'occasion de venir
dans l'église pour faire le recensement
des objets intéressants j'avais bien
repéré ce tableau mais effectivement
pour moi c'était une copie du 19e siècle
bon il faut voir que le tableau était
accroché en hauteur donc difficile
d'estimer la la qualité de la peinture
lorsque le tableau est accroché à 2,50
ou 3 m du sol une fois l'âge du tableau
déterminé par les restaurateurs les
archives du département ont fait appel à
des spécialistes de la peinture
italienne pour certifier son origine
déjà présent dans l'église à
l'inventaire en 1905 une enquête a été
lancée pour déterminer comment le
Saint-Jérôme serait arrivé à manilamo la
question reste ouverte effectivement
soit ce tableau est arrivé au 19e siècle
parce que un un riche collectionneur une
famille pouvait l'avoir chez lui avoir
voulu donner le tableau à l'église pour
faire plaisir au curé pour faire plaisir
aux mare ou ça peut très bien être aussi
un tableau offert dès le 17e siècle en
référence à ces autres ermites qui
vivent à quelques kilomètres de l'église
serv pour des raisons de sécurité le
tableau est pour l'instant conservé dans
un bureau de la mairie pour venir
l'admirer il vous faudra attendre son
retour à l'église et le début des
visites prévu le 1er mai
prochain voilà puis je vous rappelle que
sur le site internet vous pourrez aussi
retrouver l'explication complète de
Philippe Luet qui a beaucoup de choses à
dire sur ce fameux tableau la Maison de
la Poésie aguill enc organisé un weekend
d'écriture mené par l'artiste Tristan
Félix les participants ont découvert le
monocondil c'est un style graphique
byzantin datant du 10e siècle Aurélia
Debic Jonathan
Wiman d'un seul trait voilà la seule
consigne donnée au cours de l'atelier
d'écriture mené par Tristan Félix sur le
thème du monocondile une signature
enchevêtré faite de boucles et de
courbes les participants s'exercent à un
style graphique datant de l'époque
byzantine c'est en effet au cours du 10e
siècle qu'apparaît cette forme
d'écriture dont l'objectif est de rendre
la signature inimitable lors d'actes
authentiques pour Tristan Félix le tracé
imaginaire et improvisé agit comme un
révélateur de l'inconscient une
signature dont le trait continue fait
émerger ce que l'on est l'identité est
quelque chose qui me comment dire qui me
qui me passionne qui qui me
taraude je me prénomme Tristan philix
c'est évidemment pas parce que je suis
une femme mon mon nom c'est un nom de
plume un nom d'artiste j'ai une
vingtaine de pseudonymes aussi et je
pense qu'on est on est une foule on est
tous pluriel mais pour l'organisation
sociale
efficiente on nous attelle ou on nous
attribue une identité et une seule cette
idée de retrouver un fil qui parfois
dans les dans la vie de chacun a été
rompu et il faut se comment dire
s'amuser ou muser
à retrouver ce fil là sans le lâcher
voilà et à occuper sur cet espace de la
page qui est un rectangle
occuper le plus grand espace possible en
en poursuivant ce fil le plus loin
possible dans les recoins inexplorés
parce que dans la vie on on est attelé
comme je vous le disais à à des métiers
à des fonctions et on n'explore pas tous
les recoins de ce que l'on est on
n'active pas toutes les personnes que
l'on est la foule qui qui sour en nous
voilà et c'est l'occasion comme ça de de
de se
dire en s'inspirant d'un modèle ancien
un modèle ancestral qui ouvre une voix à
un nouveau mode de développement
personnel toutes les
stratégies qui permettent d'ouvrir un
espace c'est d'ouvrir un champ sur ce
que l'inattendu justement et ouvrir
toujours des portes et ce qui est
intéressant pour développer se
développer au sens large la Maison de la
poésie à guilloncour accueille pour son
son prochain weekend d'écriture les 8 et
9 février la poète dramaturge Claude ber
l'atelier sera dédié à l'univers des
héroïn voilà c'est vraiment étonnant
allez on termine cette édition avec la
3è édition du rally de la nocturne à
versaill c'était ce weekend dernier des
passionnés d'automobil pour qui les
voitures anciennes sont des reinnes
éternelles Anthony res les a
[Musique]
rencontré aller les routes ivelinoises à
bord d'une Jaguar de
1955 pour ses passionnés ce bijou de
mécanique n'a absolument pas sa place
dans un musée mais bel et bien sur le
macadame on continue à les faire vivre
ce qui est beaucoup plus important parce
que vous avez derrière nous une voiture
qui n'a jamais été restaurée qui est une
voiture qui a couru dans toute une
partie de sa vie et qui continue à
courir elle sera homoc classique elle a
été homoclassique dans les années
passées c'est c'est des voitures qui
continuent à vivre évidemment on ne
s'improvise pas spécialistes de simka de
coccinel et autres quatreiles cette
passion se transmet de génération en
génération ça vient de mon grand-père
qui avait une bonne collection qui a
transmis la passion à mon père et voilà
ça transmis de père en fils donc voilà
depuis que j'ai 15 16 ans je suis dedans
à fond bricolé tous les weekends sur ce
rally d'une centaine de kilomètres
réparti en deux étapes le chronomètre
n'avait pas d'importance se comptait la
qualité de la navigation des équipages
c'est l'esprit club c'est pouvoir se
déplacer ensemble a des vitesses à peu
près comparable qui fait que les gens
les gens arrivent à se suivre et puis
c'est la découverte hier soir on a eu
une épreuve de nuit on a roulé jusqu'à à
peu près minuit demh quelque chose comme
ça et là faut s'orienter de nuit c'est
assez compliqué la lampe de poche dans
les dents pour lire le roadbook mais
mais ça fait partie du jeu c'est très
sympa toujours aussi sympa l' dernière
il y avait de la neige les conditions
étaient moins bonnes là au moins c'était
c'était dégagé c'était sympa très très
bien à refaire
l'arrivée est souvent le pire des
moments car la chevauchée s'arrête il
faut alors ranger ces vieilles dames au
garage jusqu'à leur prochaine
parade voilà le beau bruit du moteur
allez ce 78 Act tu est maintenant
terminé merci de votre attention dans
quelques instants vous retrouvez le
kiosque l'émission culturelle présentée
par aurellia debici demain retour du 78
lactue en direct à 18h avec wilfreded
Richi il sera bien bien évidemment la
question de l'inauguration du vélodrome
de 50 ans en Yveline et puis en plateau
également avec nous Valérie pcres la
présidente départementale de l'UMP je
vous souhaite une excellente
[Musique]
soirée